Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Il dono, nella nostra cultura
di donne e uomini dell'Occidente,
richiede una giustificazione.
Non è, per così dire,
un atto consuetudinario,
un atto della vita quotidiana;
è un atto che richiede
degli eventi particolari.
Noi abbiamo creato le occasioni
per donarci, per scambiarci doni:
i compleanni;
nel sud europa gli onomastici;
alcuni eventi particolari,
le cresime e comunioni;
le ricorrenze dei matrimoni;
le nozze d'oro; le nozze d'argento.
Il Natale è questo grande evento
che è già quasi preannunciato
dalle luminarie nelle nostre città
che l'Occidente ha inventato
mettendo insieme laici, religiosi
e anche religioni diverse
per appunto consolidare insieme
questo grande evento che è il dono.
Perché nella cultura occidentale
noi non abbiamo, diciamo,
questa naturalità,
questa predisposizione al dono?
Perché noi siamo una cultura -
e non è una sottolineatura etica:
è una sottolineatura
antropologica, culturale -
che è quella del possesso delle cose,
dell'acquisto delle cose,
dello scambio delle cose.
Non abbiamo il marchio del dono
perché, nella cultura occidentale,
quello che prevale,
che ha sempre prevalso,
è la cultura dell'Io.
Di un io forte, di un io completo,
di un io che si autodefinisce
nella sua autonomia.
Pensate alla vostra terra,
pensate a questa città
che ha visto, fin dal Settecento, fiorire
figure di imprenditori saldissimi,
che hanno creato ricchezza e lavoro
appunto all'interno
di un'interpretazione della vita
attraverso un io forte, autonomo,
come quello dell'imprenditorialità.
Ci sono altre culture,
per cui si può dividere il mondo
in una sorta di dicotomia geografica:
da una parte l'occidente,
un po' ossessionato dal tema del guadagno,
dal tema del danaro,
che in questi ultimi anni -
pensate a Wall Street -
in questi ultimi anni ha esasperato
una visione finanziaria della vita;
e dall'altra un secondo, un terzo mondo,
non so più quanti siano,
dove l'io è un po più debole:
pensate alle culture dell'India,
pensate alle culture zen,
pensate alle culture
di certi paesi del sudamerica,
dove prevale di più
la solidarietà, lo scambio -
appunto, la cultura del dono.
Ripeto: non voglio dare
nessuna connotazione etica
a queste due dicotomie,
a questi due mondi.
Sono due dati culturali.
Un grande sociologo
del secolo scorso, Max Weber,
diceva che in fondo
c'è un rapporto diretto
tra lo sviluppo dell'imprenditorialità
e l'etica del protestantesimo.
Ci sono delle eccezioni:
io vengo dal Veneto,
sono nato sul lago di Garda
e sono cresciuto a Verona.
Il nordest è stato contrassegnato,
in questi ultimi anni,
nell'immaginario collettivo
del nostro paese,
come il posto dei soldi.
Gente assatanata intorno agli "schèi".
Eppure, ed è degno della massima nota,
nel Veneto ci sono
le punte più alte di volontariato.
C'è un volontariato diffuso,
soprattutto nelle giovani generazioni.
Ora, come si spiega tutto questo?
Si spiega, o meglio
ci si può riflettere sopra,
pensando che, per certi aspetti,
il dono sotto forma di servizio
è come se scomparisse.
Resta il servizio.
E il servizio, spesso,
non è visto come un dono,
ma è visto come una svolta, come dire,
volontaristica di tipo individuale
dove il collettivo diventa un fatto
abbastanza momentaneo e non stabile.
Il volontariato, il dono offerto
solo come forma di servizio
talvolta rende il dono
un gesto inconsapevole.
I miei amici volontari
del nord est del nostro paese
non sanno, in fondo, di donarsi; lo fanno.
Lo fanno con una naturalità
simile a quella che poi, di giorno,
li porta a lavorare tantissimo
intorno all'impresa, intorno al lavoro,
intorno all'accumulo
della ricchezza individuale.
Cos'è il dono?
Secondo un sociologo americano,
dono è "ogni prestazione di beni o servizi
effettuata senza garanzia
di restituzione".
Questo è il dato centrale:
si dona senza aspettare
di essere risarciti,
al fine di creare, alimentare o ricreare
il legame sociale tra le persone.
Quindi c'è un tratto del tutto oblativo
nei confronti dell'altro,
si crea un legame con l'altro
attraverso la donazione: del sé,
o di oggetti o di servizi.
Non c'è nessuna attesa
di restituzione, di scambio.
Su questa base, volevo introdurre
la seconda parte della mia riflessione
introducendo un concetto
di ambiguità rispetto al donare.
E non dò ad "ambiguità"
nessuna connotazione etica.
L'ambiguità è una
speciazione psicologica
che contiene aspetti diversi
di una realtà, molteplici,
trattenendo i quali
noi possiamo, di tale realtà,
cogliere aspetti che tendenzialmente
non riusciamo a cogliere,
anche perché scomodi,
anche perché perturbanti.
C'è un'ambiguità di primo ordine,
che sperimentiamo spesso,
anche nel nostro paese,
attraverso i media.
Padre Alex Zanotelli,
un missionario comboniano
di grande valore, un grande uomo,
recentemente ha detto:
"I poveri, in realtà,
non hanno bisogno della nostra carità,
ma solo di modifiche strutturali".
Eppure, noi doniamo:
doniamo attraverso i telefonini
due euro, cinque euro;
partecipiamo alle galoppate televisive.
Perché facciamo questo?
Probabilmente, dice padre Alex Zanotelli,
per pulirci la coscienza.
Nel caldo, nelle stanze comode
delle nostre case,
noi con un gesto - anche generoso,
anche altruistico - doniamo;
e in questo ci sentiamo tranquilli
nel partecipare a una missione collettiva
della quale non siamo artefici,
ma della quale siamo seguaci.
E che in fondo, se noi riflettiamo bene,
non risolve il problema dei donati,
che avrebbero bisogno di ben altro.
Eppure, tutto questo avviene
in maniera abbastanza diffusa, e continua,
in tutto l'Occidente.
E di fronte anche a eventi drammatici -
sono stati ricordati
i terremoti di Haiti -
noi doniamo poche lire, pochi euro;
e con questo, per certi aspetti,
laviamo le nostre coscienze di occidentali
rispetto a questo altro mondo misterioso,
nel quale succedono catastrofi
e nei confronti delle quali
"siamo solo capaci", dice Padre Zanotelli,
"di intervenire da lontano,
senza preoccuparci delle ragioni profonde
che generano quei bisogni così drammatici
in quelle popolazioni così sofferenti".
Ma c'è un'ambiguità di secondo ordine,
che forse è anche più speciosa,
forse anche più perturbante,
sulla quale riflettere insieme stamane.
Noi, come rappresentanti
di Sapiens, donne e uomini,
nasciamo mancanti.
È un dato biologico:
non è né un bene né un male.
La natura non è classificabile
in termini di difetti o di superiorità.
Le donne e gli uomini,
per una serie di situazioni
legate alla speciazione umana,
all'evoluzione
che ci ha portato a Sapiens,
nascono con un tratto
di mancanza biologica.
Cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che il cucciolo
della donna e dell'uomo,
a differenza dei cuccioli
degli animali superiori
a cui noi partecipiamo,
cioè i mammiferi,
non riescono a sopravvivere da soli.
I nostri cuccioli hanno bisogno
di qualcuno che li prenda -
una madre mediamente brava,
o chi sostituisce questa madre -
e li porta al seno.
E in questo sopravvivono.
In questo gesto fondamentale,
che spesso è dimenticato,
c'è uno stato di mancanza
che ci accompagna per tutta la vita.
E che sviluppa un sentimento di carenza.
Questo sentimento di carenza
non può essere risolto
dall'accaparramento
o dal possesso di beni;
può essere risolto solo
dalla relazione con l'altro,
che rimanda a quella antica
relazione con la madre
dalla quale noi abbiamo tratto
la nostra origine
e attraverso la quale
noi siamo sopravvissuti.
La relazione con l'altro
diventa dono, diventa scambio.
È uno scambio altruistico:
nulla è più altruistico
del gesto della madre
che porge un seno
a una piccola bocca affamata.
Nel dono c'è il riconoscimento dell'altro;
e attraverso il riconoscimento
si fonda l'identità,
che poi, sostanzialmente,
accompagna lo stato di mancanza
in una svolta però evolutiva:
noi, attraverso questo cerchio,
che è un cerchio virtuoso e non vizioso,
siamo diventati quello che siamo:
siamo qui, in questo posto
così sofisticato come un teatro,
in una città così bella come Como,
di fronte a un evento come TED,
che è un evento alto
di cultura collettiva adulta.
Tutto questo nasconde, tuttavia,
un dato di ambiguità.
Intendo, e ripeto, un qualcosa
che ci porti ad approfondire
la situazione relazionale.
Guardate queste due parole:
"Hospes" e "Hostis".
Sono due parole della lingua latina
che hanno un significato opposto, lontano:
la prima nemico, la seconda ospite.
Hanno la stessa radice hos,
che deriva dalla radice indoeuropea "Hof",
che significa casolare, casa, calore.
Nella lingua tedesca contemporanea,
Hof è tutto ciò
che indica albergo, locanda.
Dove ti danno qualcosa di buono,
ti danno un letto,
da mangiare, ospitalità.
Ma la casa rivela, contemporaneamente,
il nemico e l'ospite.
Nella casa c'è anche l'insidia:
l'ospite che arriva è intrusivo,
è qualcosa che ci trafigge,
dopo un po' di tempo,
che si mette al nostro posto.
Che dice qualcosa di inusitato
rispetto a quello che noi
siamo abituati a sentire
della nostra casa e di noi stessi.
È perturbante.
Il dono arriva inatteso
nella sua specificità,
è capace di essere intrusivo
ed interpretare aspetti
della nostra personalità
che noi non conoscevamo.
O che, se abbiamo conosciuto,
abbiamo riposto in luoghi nascosti
della nostra anima,
perché sono disturbanti.
E il dono può scavare,
può mettere in luce questi aspetti.
E allora diventa
una struttura con due facce:
una faccia positiva,
e una faccia che non è negativa in sé
ma che è una faccia perturbante
proprio perché scopre
il perturbante che è in noi.
Perché appunto scava, interpreta,
ci porta a cogliere di noi
alcuni aspetti, ripeto,
che noi al limite
conoscevamo inconsapevolmente
ma che l'atto del dono, il dono in sé,
quell'oggetto o quel servizio o quel gesto
hanno riportato alla luce.
Da un passato sepolto,
ma non per questo
meno vibrante e meno vero.
Ci sono aspetti a volte
fascinosi, in tutto questo.
Ci sono aspetti a volte inconsueti,
ci sono aspetti che perturbano,
che lasciano una striscia di non detto,
una striscia di imbarazzo,
una striscia di inconsueta
tribolazione affettiva.
Riandiamo a certi proverbi
della nostra cultura anche contadina,
della nostra cultura del secolo scorso.
L'ospite, dopo tre giorni...
Oddio, arriva la mamma:
dice che non sa quando andrà via.
Resta a lungo con noi: cosa facciamo?
L'altro ieri, in televisione,
hanno ri-proiettato un film
di Woody Allen, "Blue Jasmine",
che è la storia di due sorelle.
E quando la sorella
non sofisticata arriva a casa,
la sorella sofisticata, alta-borghese,
si preoccupa della propria vita personale
che è sconvolta dall'arrivo della sorella,
che peraltro le fa molto piacere.
Quando apriremo un dono, a Natale,
e scopriremo che non sarà
così vicino a noi,
ricordiamoci di questo incontro,
in una mattina triste
ma non per questo meno feconda.
Grazie.
(Applausi)